خلال العسكره التي تمارسها الصين في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ موقف اعلن عنه قاده
مجموعه السبع في هيروشيما
في نفس الوقت عبروا عن ارادتهم بناء علاقه
بناءه ومستقره مع بكين
القاده تؤكد ان سياستهم ليست مصممه لالحاق
الضرر بالصين لكن تعمل مجموعه السبع على
تقليل تبعيتها المفرطه للصين فيما يخص
سلاسل التوريد
حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا كانت ضمن اجنده
السبع
المجموعه دعت بكين لاستخدام تاثيرها على
موسكو لايقاف الحرب والانسحاب التام من
اوكرانيا في الحال
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات